BUT AT WHAT COST?
AN EAGLE SCOUT RESPONSE.
BUT FIRST, THE TYRANNY OF THE
JUDICIARY.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
YESTERDAY A FEDERAL DISTRICT
COURT JUDGE IN D.C., JON D
BATES, OVERTURNED
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DECISION TO
END THE DACA PROGRAM.
THE JUDGE WAS APPOINTED BY
GEORGE W. BUSH.
RULED THAT TRUMP 'ACTION WAS
ARBITRARY BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY FAILED
ADEQUATELY TO SLAIN ITS
CONCLUSION THAT THE PROGRAM WAS
UNLAWFUL.
WELL, THIS JUDGE ORDERED THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONTINUE TO
ACCEPT NEW DACA ACT APPLICANTS.
DELAYING THE IMITATION FOR 90
DAYS FOR THE TRUMP FOLKS CAN
REWRITE THEIR BASIS FOR ENDING
DACA.
IF THIS RULING STANDS, IT COULD
ACTUALLY MEAN THAT TRIPLING OF
THE NUMBER OF ILLEGALS
ULTIMATELY PROTECTED BY THIS
OBAMA AIR PROGRAM.
DACA WOULD THEN BE OPEN TO AN
ADDITIONAL 1.2 MILLION MORE
PEOPLE, ACCORDING TO AN ANALYSIS
BY THE MIGRATION POLICY
INSTITUTE.
THAT IS ON TOP OF THE NEARLY
700,000 ALREADY PROTECTED BY THE
PROGRAM.
THE VERY IDEA THAT ONE UNELECTED
DISTRICT COURT JUDGE COULD HAVE
THIS TYPE OF POWER SHOULD
OUTRAGE EVERY AMERICAN.
I DON'T THINK ANY SERIOUS LEGAL
SCHOLAR REALLY THINKS THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY TO
WAIVE HIS NOBLE HAND AND GRANT
700,000 YOUNG PEOPLE DE FACTO
CITIZENSHIP.
REMEMBER, HE GAVE THEM THE RIGHT
TO WORK HERE WITHOUT FEAR OF ANY
DEPORTATION, ALL BY THIS
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
REMEMBER, WHEN THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE A MAJORITY IN CONGRESS,
THEY FAILED TO PASS BROAD-BASED
AMNESTY.
SO OBAMA, THROUGH HIS HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY JANET
NAPOLITANO, DECIDED HE WILL DO
IT ON HIS OWN.
THIS WAS DONE DESPITE THE
MISGIVINGS OF HIS OWN JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
BUT NEVERTHELESS, OBAMA PUSHED
IT AS FAR AS HE COULD.
>> THE BILL HASN'T REALLY
CHANGED.
THE NEED HASN'T CHANGED.
IT IS STILL THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
THE ONLY THING THAT'S CHANGED
APPARENTLY WAS THE POLITICS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO EXPEL
TALENTED YOUNG PEOPLE WHO, FOR
ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES, ARE
AMERICANS.
>> Laura: THE WHOLE
CITIZENSHIP THING, MILLIONS WHO
CAME HERE ILLEGALLY TO GET
CITIZENSHIP, THAT'S ALL A
FORMALITY, MR. PRESIDENT.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMIN'S RATION DID BY RESCINDING
DACA WAS TO ACTUALLY RESTORE THE
RULE OF LAW AND RETURN
IMMIGRATION DECISIONS AND THE
FATE OF THOSE DACA KIDS TO THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY APPROPRIATE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, CONGRESS.
YET DISTRICT COURT JUDGES FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO BROOKLYN AND
NOW HERE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
HAVE STYMIED THIS PRESIDENT AT
EVERY TURN.
THIS IS TOTALLY ABSURD AND AN
ABUSE OF POWER.
NOW, YOU MIGHT BE ASKING
YOURSELF HOW WE GOT HERE.
AND HOW DID WE GET TO A POINT
WHERE PEOPLE FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES BELIEVE THEY CAN CRASH
OUR BORDERS, GAME OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, AND
ULTIMATELY JUST WANDER FREELY IN
OUR COUNTRY?
WELL, THE ANSWER, ONE
OUT-OF-CONTROL JUDGE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE A LOT TO DO WITH
IT.
HER NAME IS GEORGE DOLLY D.
IN 2014, WE SAW OF THE MASS
INFLUX OF ILLEGALS CROSSING OUR
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
REMEMBER THE OBAMA DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY PLACED A LOT
OF THOSE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
FAMILY UNITS IN DETENTION
FACILITIES.
WELL, IN 2015, JUDGE GEE RULED
THAT THE GOVERNMENT COULD NOT
DETAIN THE CHILDREN IN CENTER
SET UP.
ALTHOUGH CENTERS IN TEXAS
BECAUSE THE JUDGE RULED THEY
WERE NOT SAFE AND SANITARY
ENOUGH.
SHE BASED THAT DECISION ON THIS
1997 SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT THAT
WAS CALLED THE FLOREZ CASE, THAT
REQUIRED THAT UNACCOMPANIED
ALIEN MINORS BE RELEASED INTO
THE COUNTRY WITHOUT DELAY.
THIS JUDGE GEE WENT FURTHER,
RULING THAT NOT ONLY SHOULD THE
MINORS BE RELEASED INTO THE
UNITED STATES ONCE APPREHENDED
BUT THEIR PARENTS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO GO FREE AS WELL.
SO AGAIN, THAT ONE DISTRICT
JUDGE IN CALIFORNIA IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE RELEASE OF
AN ESTIMATED 107,000
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THIS COUNTRY SINCE
THE YEAR 2016.
AND THEN ALSO MOST OF THE
167,000 APPREHENDED FAMILY UNITS
RELEASED AS WELL.
AGAIN, THINK THIS THROUGH.
ONE DISTRICT COURT JUDGE HAS
FOREVER CHANGED OUR CULTURAL,
DEMOGRAPHIC, AND ECONOMIC,
PERHAPS NATIONAL SECURITY
LANDSCAPE.
ONE JUDGE.
THAT IS NOT WHAT OUR FOUNDERS
INTENDED.
NOW LET'S FACE IT.
THE RUNAWAY JUDICIARY HAS BECOME
IN EFFECT A NEW FLANK OF THE
RESISTANCE.
THEY ARE TAKING AWAY YOUR POWER.
COME AND IT'S TIME FOR CONGRESS
TO CIRCUMSCRIBE THE AUTHORITY AD
THE REACH OF THESE DISTRICT
COURT JUDGES.
THINK ABOUT NATIONAL HEALTH CARE
POLICY, IMMIGRATION POLICY,
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THESE MATTERS ARE ALL BEYOND THE
SCOPE AND UNDERSTANDING FRANKLY
OF A DISTRICT COURT JUDGE.
IT'S LIKE GIVING A LOCAL MIRROR
CONTROL OVER U.S. FOREIGN
POLICY.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
REMEMBER, THE CONSTITUTION
ARTICLE THREE SECTION ONE STATES
THE FOLLOWING.
THE JUDICIAL POWER OF THE
UNITED STATES SHALL BE VESTED IN
ONE SUPREME COURT AND IN SUCH
INFERIOR COURTS AS THE CONGRESS
MAY FROM TIME TO TIME ORDAIN AND
ESTABLISH.
IT CONTINUES.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS CONGRESS CAN REGULATE
THE LOWER COURT JURISDICTION.
IT'S TIME THEY DO.
IN FACT, THEY HAVE DONE SO IN
THE PAST.
CONGRESS SHOULD IMMEDIATELY PASS
LEGISLATION THAT ESTABLISHES ANY
CASES TOUCHING ON IMPORTANT
NATIONAL SECURITY OR NATIONAL
ECONOMIC CONCERNS SHOULD
BE REFERRED TO THE APPEALS COURT
BE REFERRED TO THE APPEALS COUR
COURT.
OR THE SUPREME COURT DIRECTLY
WITHOUT DELAY.
OR AT THE VERY LEAST,
CONSTITUTIONAL DETERMINATIONS OF
THE TYPE WE ARE SEEING IN THIS
DACA CASE.
THEY SHOULD BE REFERRED TO THE
APPELLATE JUDGES, THREE-JUDGE
PANEL OR MAYBE AN ON BANC PANEL
OF THE WHOLE COURT.
THEY ARE FAR MORE KNOWLEDGEABLE
ON CONSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGEABLE
ON CONSTITUTIONAL
AND ALL THESE MATTERS.
THE TYRANNY ESPECIALLY OF THE
DISTRICT COURT BENCH HAS TO END.
THE PEOPLE'S WILL SHOULD NO
LONGER BE HELD HOSTAGE TO THE